[Music]
guys guys we've gotta go we've got a run
mom knows what you did to her dress and
mom found your pants under the bed late
days later
happy birthday I told you I wouldn't
forget it's the new Taiwan SPR speed
griddle run we need to get out of here
we need to get out of town let's go oh
man you guys are in so much trouble we
have got to get out of town you remember
what happened last time we tried to hide
for mommy were you followed no you sure
about that
you sure mother can't find us yeah it's
a we've gotta hide further and better
than we've ever had before are you guys
ready for that
lon can track the car we've got to get
rid of the car all right we got rid of
the car now let's make some tracks right
[Music]
tell me you grab that rope and hold it
tight all right this is where we're
gonna camp for the night I think mom
will find us no we'll be safe
[Music]
[Music]
alright guys we are doing some stealth
camping today and by stealth camping I
mean no one will ever know we were here
we are gonna leave no trace this hammock
tent is perfect for that
there's no real flat ground and you
don't want to be clearing brush and
digging up earth so the hammock tent is
perfect for that additionally if you
have anything you want to keep dry you
have plenty of room to throw it
underneath the hammock hey guys
you having fun I've got my fishing gear
here we're gonna try to reel in some
catfish tonight but also I'm gonna get a
roaring fire going but I mentioned this
is gonna be Leave No Trace camping how
are we gonna build a roaring fire and
Leave No Trace I have the hammock fire
pit let me show you this thing alright
this is the hammock fire pit it's
basically a galvanized steel wash bin
from a hardware store I drilled some
one-and-a-half inch holes along the side
for air flow then I attached chains to
the handles with some carabiners on the
end and this allows you to string the
fire pit up keep it off the ground so it
doesn't burn the ground and it allows
you to do some pretty awesome cooking
and baking alright got the spot between
two trees where we've got a little bit
of space we're gonna hang up the fire
pit to hang up the fireplace I'm using
the Ferryman's friction hitch it's kind
of like the midshipman's knot it's an
adjustable knot where you can adjust the
length of the rope by sliding the knot
back and forth and it's a quick release
knot you just pull the tag end and the
whole thing comes undone if you want to
know how to tie this knot along with
other great camping knots check out the
link below to my top eight favorite
knots it's a great video well there we
go there's the hammock fireplace I got
it strung up to this tree and to that
tree and these extra chains here you can
put there and there and that'll keep it
from swaying if you don't want to worry
about that there we go we have a nice
fire pit that won't leave any trace on
the ground has no burnable material
overhead and it's safe and secure
all right I've got my blast match a
little bit of Duke blast match is just a
ferrous rod with this bit of steel here
and you go and it makes a spark when you
stab it like that this fire pit works
pretty good but I should have drilled
the holes just a touch higher because
every once in a while an ember falls out
and it's not a big deal except for you
just don't want a bunch of dry grass or
something underneath the fire pit I've
got a bunch of these flat rocks so I'm
gonna go ahead and put them underneath
well I prepared three different types of
kabobs for dinner today I've got bacon
wrapped chicken I've got chicken mixed
with peppers and squash and mushrooms
and onions and I've got pineapple
and chicken chunks mixed together you
can prepare these things in advance and
they're so easy and quick to cook up
great campfire food
[Music]
all right got the shish kebobs in these
bags here we're gonna add some barbecue
sauce to the bags let that get all
coated all over oh yeah
that's looking good here buddy have some
you know I mean is that good
Oh shish kebabs are so good such an easy
thing to do on a campout oh good you
want a roast marshmallows okay go get
yourself a marshmallow stick okay all
right let's let's sharpen that sucker up
okay on a pig marshmallow look look at
the size of that thing you don't want to
sit your butter on the ground because
you get you'll get your butt wet there
you go
sit on that log that is a big freakin
marshmallow right there
there we go you Thomas
I got a marshmallow for you you like
that you like the marshmallow one really
cool thing about this hammock fire pit
is that you can bake things underneath
it it gets about two to four hundred
degrees underneath here depending on how
high off the ground you get it and so I
got these rocks here and the the rocks
have been warming up and retaining some
heat so now we're gonna cook some
brownies underneath our hammock fire pit
you need is that you like that there you
go lick this food that's all you I think
I think you got a little chocolate on
your face the gap between the bottom of
your fire pit and the top of your pan
has to be nice and even and it has to be
the right amount just kind of gotta
figure out by trial and error how high
to get it off the pan but you just use
these little knots and just slide them
up and down a little bit to kind of
level things out and adjust it alright
let's check out the brownies let's see
if they cooked at all oh there's a gooey
kind of gooey didn't quite hit that
right the middle parts done yeah the
middle part kind of worked kind of more
of a lava cake but yeah yeah we got some
brownie here you want tray you like that
[Laughter]
baking under a fire pit is a lot harder
than baking in a conventional oven and
certain recipes are harder than others
this is my first time trying brownies
and yeah it was didn't work very well
but I've done cookies and I've done
coffee cake and that worked really well
so yeah I kind of hit miss you
that looks like a pile of poop but it
tastes really good right there okay you
like that warm brownie goo on a cold day
all right it's time to get the boys
ready for bed and I'm going to show you
my little secret here I've got these hot
hands adhesive body warmers there are
large hand warmers with stickers on the
back and they are great for keeping
people warm and this is what I bring
with me when I already take my kids
camping so that if they ever get cold I
just slap a bunch of these on them and
they're good to go you want some hand
warmers buddy there you go take the
little sticker off this yeah I'm gonna
slap another one on your chest
all right you know like those those were
good dumb all right hop on in there get
it bro did anything you stayed warm
all right buddy burro burro in there as
deep as you can okay we're gonna zip you
up all right you good Nathan okay good
night bud
poor Beck is probably at home worried
sick of us crying herself to sleep I
feel bad about that I really do
[Music]
I have two boys fed into bed and I might
do a little bit of fishing now it's the
middle of winter though so the fish
aren't close to shore they're out deep
in the middle of the channel so I'm
gonna use my little skiff here and do a
little long-distance shore fishing here
while I hang out by the fire okay I got
some frozen shad here that's what we're
gonna use for bait there we go all right
I've taken the boat out of about 100
yards from shore I'm gonna drop my baits
off the side then I'm gonna drive back
to shore with my rods and then I'm gonna
wait for bite on the shore it's a great
way to long-distance fish and that's
exactly what we need to do here I've got
both rods in the rod holders and I've
got the bait clickers on so the fish
grabs my line I'll make that nice loud
noise and I'm sitting here over by shore
I'm just gonna go hang out by the fire
and my boys and listen for a bite well
it's only about ten o'clock but I'm
exhausted so I'm gonna go hit the sack
I'm only a few feet away from my fishing
rod so something grabs the line really
runs with it all here the bait clickers
going and maybe we'll catch a fish in
the middle of the night but I'm going to
sleep and get these kids to bed well
it's the middle of the night I just
heard my line flicker go off pretty
aggressively
right there well the rod on the left is
hung up and the rod on the right has two
fish and I think the fish went and
wrapped itself around the line that's
hung up I gotta go take the boat out and
get it unstuck well I've got 50 pound
line on these reels so I'm just gonna
reel the rod that's hung up and that's
gonna drag the boat to where the catfish
is and we're gonna deal with it from
there
well hold that didn't take long yeah
there you are okay he is literally got
both of my rigs oh it was barely hooked
well there you go nice fat channel
catfish and I got both my rigs back so
not too bad but it's cold out here so
I'll put him back it's below freezing
give you an idea how cold it is out here
that's my wet bait tell well I
definitely keep fishing if I wanted to
but it is cold and super late so I'm
going to bed guys
I'll see you in the morning it's morning
time
well I was gonna be worried about it so
we better ruin going home and face to
music but this has been fun we've had a
we've had a good time Sylla firepit is
so light it's lighter than a cast-iron
skillet
well there we go put away the fire pit
and it would take a forensic scientist
know we were over there hey hey it's
cold isn't it now do you guys want to
get dressed or do you want to ride home
in your sleeping bags okay we'll do that
I don't believe you getting out of the
sleeping bags is the worst part
this stingray three man hammock tends
kind of a funky tent but I really kind
of like it and the boys enjoy because
it's so bouncy and you can set it up in
places you can't set up on other tents
if you want to see a full review of this
tent I'll put a link in the description
to a video I did reviewing this a tent
and going camping in it for the first
time guys you have fun did you hear the
animal go under the tent last night yeah
middle of the night I was sitting there
and I could all of a sudden hear
something like a skunk or a raccoon come
crawling along down the hill and he came
right up to the tent and then stopped
and I kind of made a little noise and he
scurried off it was kind of it was kind
of creepy well there's our campsite
you'd have to be an Apache Scout to know
whether or not anyone's ever been here
all right guys you all ready to go home
face mom
[Music]
you have fun well guys I hope you
enjoyed this fun little video if you
want to see more great camping videos
we've got a ton of them whole playlists
in fact so check that out I'll put links
in the description also if you want to
see tutorials like knot-tying tutorials
how to start fires without matches
campfire cooking tutorials I've gotten
those as well I'll put links in the
description thanks for watching don't
forget to click Subscribe and if you
want to see more fishing check out my
other YouTube channel the catfish and
carp YouTube jail thanks for watching
if you like this video don't forget to
check out the outdoor boys youtube
channel where we have hundreds of videos
just like this and don't forget to click
subscribe so you can see other great
videos every Saturday morning hit that
Bell button you'll get
thanks for watching
[Music]